little reject nation john marston
I just found out this came out the
official gameplay trailer numero dos for
Red Dead Redemption numero dos
I wanted to take a moment to clear a
couple things up from the last reaction
that I did I didn't watch the video back
I was in a rush as I was going in movie
fights apparently I said something that
led a bunch of people to believe that I
didn't actually finish the game that I
stopped playing right after John Marston
died I was just expressing that I was
annoyed that he died I was very much
frustrated by that I know that you play
as I beat the game you play as his son
at the end he gets his revenge but that
still honestly I feel like for some
people a lot of people have talked about
jte at screen jockeys about this eve was
very much satisfied with that ending and
he felt that vengeance come on it and I
was there playing the game to like yeah
I'm gonna kill this [ __ ] till
doesn't take away the fact that what he
died I still had that feeling of man
went through all that and now he's dead
cuz I only got back into gaming again
this year I've really been taking my
time I've made it just a casual hobby
I've only been about four games this
year Red Dead Redemption being one of
them easily committed the most time to
that cave I wanted to clear that up
secondly I wanted to thank you to
everyone who educated me on the fact
that Red Dead Redemption 2 is actually a
prequel hearing that this is the gang
that's constantly being talked about and
referenced in the first Red Dead
Redemption that was actually really cool
to learn you know you call something
part two you think it's a continuation
you don't think it's a prequel and I did
not go on a Wikipedia page or something
to find that out beforehand so I'm sorry
I'm excited who watch this let's hop
into this shall we
that's a lot of great reasons to be
mature am i right
with Red Dead Redemption too much better
the graphics to create its most
ambitious open-world experience today it
is an epic tale about one life it
seamlessly blends story to action an
exploration with choice all under the
constant threat of danger I did love
this game as you move fluidly from one
moment to another
know what to do Arthur can undertake a
wide array of nefarious activities with
his fellow gang members some are large
scale height you can rob a train
passerby or a coach hold up a store
forego a house or go loan-sharking for
money or you can simply go off and
explore alone if you're feeling brave
enough the countryside is much more what
I want to give too big yeah how's that
score you stole offers rich one in this
rapidly civilizing world who lawmen are
hunting weather tracking known outlaws
or investigating a crime scene I'm not a
film to pass a quick judgment I know you
don't hire a saint to catch a sinner get
a price on your head and bounty
knock you down Arthur must always be
prepared to defend himself with nice Oh
near the gore is increased your
experience is defined by the choices and
decisions you make for Arthur you can of
course choose what to wear right eat and
which guns to carry shave bathe or don't
it's up to you Dead Redemption two
things
that's my favorite hurting it's my
favorite part of the game poker I wasted
it's way too much time playing poker cut
up some log wood hey I was never good at
that and even but in real life I'm guys
there's the graphics there's so much
better remember you and your options you
can also really
oh do this that's great new cinematic
cameras for some stunning news
the result is a world a lot of great
things reveal here man
in terms of just story wise I know it's
a prequel finding out it's a prequel
actually really excited me I cuz I feel
like the the route that everyone thought
this game was originally gonna go down
was he just play as john marston son and
this plotline I love it because there
was so much stories and references and
mystery to what the gang life was when
John Marston was a part of that crew and
now we get to explore be a part of that
adventure and be on the run before I
ever played Red Dead how it was pitched
to me was its Grand Theft Auto but in
the Wild West
Wow and then I find out that you're
playing as a good guy which was fun and
I still really love the game I was a
very easy game to get addicted to for
sure but there was that missing element
for me of I want to be an outlaw I want
to be a bad guy and I know in the first
game there's so much of that sense of
identity of can you really escape your
pass of being an outlaw but here you
know you just you just get to be the bad
guy it's cool robbed the banks and
everything I like the enhancements of
the Dead Eye shot of the more attention
to detail of specific points you can
actually him I think the way she she
phrased it was you can see critical and
fatal points of your enemies which is
awesome because it took me a long while
to pick up on the the marking system I
had to wait till I got to that mission
with the with a really old cowboy guy I
don't know if that's in the game when
when you can officially do that part or
I just did not realize you could do it
before and I like that enhancement level
to go in the first-person point of view
that looks really cool I like how you
have the option to do that as opposed to
you are stuck with doing that it took me
a little while to pick up on handling
the controls there but I like the idea
of feeling even more immersed in this
world because I don't know if
first-person point of view will be the
primary way I play this game I'll just
have to feel it out look
here you know in a game that's so about
being immersed into the open world I
feel like that might actually enhance it
and they did touch on it and the last
gameplay trailer you know how like your
choices and consequences will affect the
outcome of your tale I'm wondering how
much that'll really do that because at
the end of the day the first Red Dead
had a linear storyline that it had to
follow here what does that mean you
could get a totally different ending
than someone else who's playing the game
will you get a different outcome and
someone else is playing the game we're
at the end of they will still fall under
your character going under the same main
plot points or will the plot points be
entirely different depending on how you
choose to go about handling things and I
also got to say to the attention to
detail the only thing that I thought was
I don't know if crap for Zionism but the
the the thing that I thought was missing
for me was better graphics and that was
it
but the thing I respect about Rockstar
and how they handle their games a lot of
the time is they don't just keep dishing
this out like people want to read Dead
Redemption to you for quite some time
they don't just keep turning these hey
it's like fake a crit game and then
spend a few more years developing
another a great game and that's and
that's what they got right here the
graphics here are so much better than
the last one just even like when people
are getting shot in everything you can
feel the impact you could feel the gore
I really love it but anyway before I
wrap this video up I wanted to give a
patron today shout out to a man named
low heat then our jibon RG sorry if i'm
pronouncing your name wrong buddy he has
been a patron for about a week maybe a
week and a half at this point and he was
one of the higher reward tiers basically
that comes with patron video requests
whatever video you requested was
definitely due and put up on YouTube
handwritten thank-you letter and a shout
out of course now I'm shining you out
because I don't know you at all low heat
I've messaged you a couple of times now
in the past two weeks trying to get a
hold of you to honor your reward tier if
you're watching this video can you
please check your messages on patreon so
that way I can properly honor the reward
tier I mean we appreciate the
contribution well accept the
contribution that ain't a prob but I
grew up Catholic so not being able to
hold up my end of the bargain is
amplifying my level of guilt I looked
your name that says a Sanskrit name for
boys meaning red and copper and you know
who else's name copper my kitty cat
named copper hmm see this is you low
heat this is you right here looky mmm
you're so adorable low heat you're so
adorable though he'd you're free you're
free light subscribe to the region that
notification bell and check us out up a
tree I got TV show reactions q and A's a
whole bunch of goodies would love to
have you become a patron objector